gaius happy self-quarantine Kylie Jenner
may be in quarantine but that's not
stopping her from dropping some serious
cash on a new house I'm having fun
according to multiple reports the 22
year old just paid a whopping thirty six
point five million dollars on a property
in the exclusive Los Angeles
neighborhood Holmby Hills yeah
thirty-six point five million dollars
but she got a huge discount on the not
so humble abode it was originally listed
for fifty five million it's funny yeah
so it's actually more like a shopping
mall and less like a house featuring
seven bedrooms fourteen bathrooms and
twenty parking spots it's a single-story
modern compound fifteen thousand three
hundred and fifty square feet to be
exact and has a dedicated guardhouse a
chef's kitchen and outdoor projection
screen home theater bars and game rooms
a gym and a championship-level sports
court with pickleball and basketball
oh and it also has two guest apartments
so where do we apply now a source tells
ET that while kylie has a house in
Calabasas near her famous family she's
wanted to buy a house in LA for a while
now and finally found the one that works
for her quote she wanted something in LA
for when she goes out with friends or
has business meetings or gigs in LA and
doesn't want to go back to Calabasas yep
this is her crash pad folks fifteen
thousand three hundred and fifty square
feet thirty six point five million
dollar over the top gorgeous crash pad
but it's also an investment the source
adds Kylie is really into real estate
and expanding her portfolio and couldn't
pass up this opportunity safety is a
major concern for Kylie and this home
has an area for dedicated security
state-of-the-art security system and a
security gate and guys she's earned it
she works really hard of course in 2019
Kyle
was named Forbes youngest self-made
billionaire at the time the beauty mogul
and Forbes received a lot of flack some
people just couldn't get behind the
title self-made noting that the Keeping
Up with the Kardashians star had the
help of her famous family to build her
fortune it's not like that was handed to
her she figured that all out I mean we
all have at the time Kylie's sister Kim
and her mama defended her title to et
she made her own money for over a decade
she put it in the bank
she saved every nickel and then when she
decided she really you know decided on
what she wanted to do she spent her
money on a venture that could have gone
south or north and it did really well
[Music]